Doug Jeffrey: Educated at the University of
Rochester and at the Wilson School of Public
and International Affairs at Princeton.
He began his career at the Federal Reserve
Bank of New York.
He served as chief economist and senior managing
director at Bear Stearns, and during the first
Reagan term he was the associate director
for economics of planning in the Office of
Management and Budget.
He is currently a senior contributor at CNBC,
where he hosted for a long time The Kudlow
Report.
He has a weekly syndicated radio show.
He's a nationally syndicated columnist, contributing
editor at National Review, and he's CEO of
Kudlow & Company LLC, an economic research
firm.
Last, but far from least, he's a recipient
of numerous awards, most of them related to
his philanthropic works, including the Bishop's
Humanitarian Award from the Catholic Charities
of Brooklyn and Queens, the Humanitarian Award
from the Pregnancy Care Center of New Rochelle,
New York, and the Ambassadors for Mission
Award from the Pontifical Mission Societies
of the United States.
It's an honor really to introduce you to tonight
to speak on the economic debates going on
today, Mr. Larry Kudlow.
Larry Kudlow: Thank you.
Appreciate it very much.
It's a pleasure, honor to be here to help
Hillsdale in any way that I can.
Let me begin, as I was instructed by the organizers,
to talk about the prospects of capitalism,
the prospects of capitalism.
If you know me and if you've seen any of the
stuff I've done on the air you know I'm a
quintessential optimist, quintessential optimist.
I will you I think the prospects of capitalism
are pretty good, pretty good.
They're not as good as I want them to be.
We have a few issues.
But they're pretty good.
Let me make this caveat.
If you take nothing else away from this talk
tonight, let me tell you this.
If we want free markets, and limited government,
and sound money, and low taxes, and deregulation,
and market choice and competition, if want
to be part of the great traditional of Milton
Friedman, or Friedrich Hyek, or Ludwig Von
Mesis, or Arthur Laffer, and many others,
if want to be optimistic about the great country
of our ours and the great economy of ours,
we, you and I, are going to have to fight
like hell to preserve it.
They are not going to give it to us on a silver
platter.
They are trying to gobble up as much as they
can.
We kicked their butt in the last midterm election
but one never knows.
Presidential politics is funny thing.
A thought.
Since World War II the US economy, generally
a free market economy, has grown at an average
yearly rate of 3.3%.
That's from roughly 1947 to 2000.
Did you know that over the last century, from
1900 to 2000, I think that's a hundred years,
the US economy has grown at an annual rate
of 3.4%?
That's pretty good.
I'm going to argue that there is no nation
in the history of history, no nation with
a free market capitalist experiment in the
history of history, who has ever produced
that kind of economic growth over that long
a period of time ever, ever.
I will also say this.
The great experiments of communism and Nazism
and fascism and totalitarianism, and I'm going
to talk more about totalitarianism in a few
minutes, all those great experiments, we're
seeing a few of them now redux.
I thought when I was a young working for Reagan
I'd put a spike into Maynard Keynes and redistribution
and taxing the rich.
I could have sworn I had him in the crypt,
but I was wrong.
He's back.
This is a fight worth preserving, not only
because of its track record.
It's a fight worth preserving for the generations
ahead of us, for the unborn.
That's why this is so important.
As your president said, this is something
that will not come easily, constitutionally,
regutatorily, taxly, spendingly.
This will not come easily.
However, however, however, I'm a great believer
that democracies breed free market capitalism.
Now you can argue, and you'd be right, that
that is not always the case.
Now I will argue of course that democracies
do not breed any sort of state planning and
seizing the means of production, but you could
point to Europe and say they have democracies
but they don't really have much of form of
capitalism.
They actually have some form of capitalism
in Europe.
It's their own little design.
It doesn't work.
They haven't grown in decades, but it's something.
We've had a lot of influence down through
the years, particularly in the last three
decades with Reagan and Thatcher putting into
place the ideas of Milton Friedman and Friedrich
Hayek and the others I mentioned.
We've had some influence in Asia.
In fact I'll tell you a story in Asia.
Now I'm not going to point to China as a democracy.
Will note however that the communist rules
have opened the economy up quite a bit.
They've liberalized it in the direction of
markets, in the direction of markets, in the
direction of ownership.
So much so that I don't believe that the communists
will be able to remain in power.
Once you let that genie out of the bottle
it usually can never be put back in, but we'll
see.
On the other hand, hundreds of millions of
people have improved their lot in China and
so they now have a large, burgeoning middle
class.
The same thing is true in India.
India is a democracy, thankfully, and it has
a long history of socialist bureaucratic underperforms
the economy, but nonetheless, in the recent
decade or so, and maybe even more coming now
with a open market guy, a free market guy
running it, India, hundreds of millions of
people have come to enjoy middle class status.
This is new.
They're basically following the Reagan-Thatcher
model.
That's what they're doing.
There's a long tradition of that in the United
States and in the English-seapking countries.
That's what freedom will do.
I have had my disagreements.
I do a lot of service for the Catholic Church,
quite true.
Far be it from me to criticize the pope, who
doesn't share my zest for free market capitalism.
That's as strong as I'm going to get on that
subject.
I did get a call.
It's important if you're a Catholic to get
a call.
I got a call from the Archbishop of New York,
Cardinal Dolan.
Never met the guy before.
I sat down with a few of his people and some
big church people.
We were talking about what to do with some
of the pope's proclamations about free market
capitalism.
One guy in particular said, "You know eminence,
we're trying to raise 2-300 million dollars
here to fix the roof of the church," which
is a noble enterprise, St. Patrick's Church.
It's a landmark.
It's very important, and people worship there.
Don't want the roof to fall on their head.
This guy said, "It's very hard if the pope
keeps making these proclamations against rich
people who are here to provide the 2 or 300
million dollars to fix your roof."
By the way, I'm not a theoretician as it must
be apparent.
I see life in very practical, real world terms.
He said, "I'm bringing Kudlow in here.
I'm want you to meet Larry Kudlow, who believes
in free market capitalism, and he'd like to
talk to you."
I said, "Eminence, look.
I want you to write an op-ed piece.
I'm not here to suggest that you're going
to attack the holy father, but I am here to
suggest that we can write you an op-ed piece
that will provide you a little more balance
in the story."
I took out a graph, a chart, from the World
Bank, which is a left-wing organization.
The chart basically says, with great clarity,
over the last three decades, which has been
the rising tide of the spread of free market
capitalism around the world, the rate of abject
dollar a day poverty has fallen by 80%, 80%.
That number is so big and so convincing of
the merits of free market capitalism that
it deserves at least some papal attention.
Now I'm going to leave that alone.
I'm not here to talk to you about the Catholic
Church.
I could tell you jokes and I'm not going to
go there.
It's much too serious an evening tonight,
but I'm proud of it and it's working.
Look, we've had periods of time when the country
has moved to the left, but the good news is
it never really stays to the left.
Now you may disagree with that.
I appreciate that.
We could probably debate some of that but
that is my particular view.
Somehow over the last hundred years we've
grown at almost 3.5% per year.
I think that's remarkable.
I was chatting on air a week or two ago with
my pal Glenn Beck.
He was interviewing me on one thing or another.
He fancies himself a classical liberal, which
is kind of a cool terms, a classical liberal.
I love to take their language away for them.
I always have.
Thank you.
What's a classical liberal?
We were kind of going at this.
You're a classical ... I said, "Yeah, it's
Hayek, it's Milton Friedman."
I'd just think yeah, you know what?
If I had lived in the 19th century I would
have been a Gladstonian.
I would have been a follower of William Gladstone,
four-time liberal prime minister of Britain.
What did he believe in?
It turns out a couple of guys in The Economist
had actually written a piece.
I went and googled it up and they call it
Gladstonian republicanism and said the GOP
should learn from Gladstone.
It was 150 years ago, whatever, but he actually
cut the size of the British government by
a third during a period when their economy
expanded by 50%.
Britain ruled the waves and had the greatest
economy in the world.
He's slashing government, virtually abolishing
taxes, virtually abolishing tariffs, and virtually
abolishing regulations.
Actually, the liberal in our welfare big government
entitlement terms was Disraeli.
He was supposed to be the conservative.
Glenn Beck and I talked about the need for
classical liberalism to return.
That's what I'm saying to you this evening.
We can do this.
We know what we're doing.
If we're well rooted in the theory, if we
know the difference between right and wrong,
we can go after the bad guys.
Look at what we've done.
Don't talk to me about a couple bad years
of stagnant middle class wages.
I get that.
By the way, my pal Alan Reynolds just did
a study and said the top 1% has lost money
in the whole bunch of last years too.
You can't have a healthy economy without rich
people.
Can I just say that?
You cannot have a healthy economy without
someone succeeding.
Someone has to succeed in order to create
wealth.
I don't know.
We had dinner with President Obama just before
the inauguration at George Will's house.
It's a tradition because he's George Will.
There were nine or ten of us conservative
yappers.
We met the president.
It was charming and sort of humorous, well
turned out.
He was humorous until Krauthammer went at
him and then he kind of lost his sense of
humor.
I asked about marginal tax rates.
He was talking 40s on the way to 50.
Bill Kristol or somebody asked him about healthcare
and he was talking about his grandmother's
hip or something and how the state took care
of it.
I knew we were in for trouble.
I knew right then and there.
But look, it's not stopping progress.
It's not stopping progress.
It's weakened it, it's slowed it, but it's
not stopped it.
The whole issue of freedom and rewarding success
is never going to be stopped.
It is in the very roots of democracy, the
very roots of democracy, the very roots of
constitutional rule.
I have a simple definition.
I want lower marginal tax rates.
Hell, I'd take a flat tax any day of the week.
I want government cut to the bone.
I want regulations as light as possible.
I want sound money, a reliable dollar, so
people can invest here.
Of course I want the rule of law.
The president has violated pretty much all
of those things, but there is some good news.
As his term comes to an end I notice the dollar
is going up.
This is good.
As many of us have argued for many years,
as the dollar goes up the price of oil goes
down.
This is also good.
This is helping middle class people, because
their dollars will be worth more.
All commodities are going down, and food prices
are going down along with energy and gasoline
prices.
Even though the president encouraged the Fed
to create 4.5 trillion new dollars in their
balance sheet and hates fossil fuel, we are
benefiting because the Federal Reserve has
finally stopped printing money and fossil
fuel has created one of the technological
energy revolutions in our history, so I'll
prices are closer to 50 than 150.
I don't mind if the president takes credit
for that.
The presidents do but he didn't have a bloody
thing to do with it.
It's just happening because we are basically
still a free market democracy and a free market
economy.
Guys like Harold Hamm going up to North Dakota
and saying I can frack, I can do horizontal
drilling, nobody believed him.
He did it anyway and that's still the great
spirit of free market capitalism.
It is alive and well.
Look, in our lifetime we've gone from industry
to technology and information and the internet,
in our lifetime.
You know how important that is?
We led the we.
We, the US, led the way.
You know why?
Because we were free to do so.
You know what else?
People who led this revolution were able to
get rewards for their successful risk talking
and entrepreneurship.
That's what happened.
As long as that model survives ... My pal
Arthur Brooks who runs the American Enterprise
Institute writes about this wonderful stuff,
the immorality of punishing success and the
morality of rewarding success.
As you know from the Declaration of Independence,
our creator endowed us with inalienable rights
of life, liberty, and the pursuit of happiness.
It is the pursuit of happiness part that interests
me a lot.
Life?
Yes.
Liberty?
Pursuit of happiness means you are free to
fail or succeed.
In so doing you will produce great things
that nobody believed possible.
I don't ever, ever want to lose that freedom.
That's why I say to you tonight, the outlook
for free market capitalism's pretty good but
you're going to have to fight like hell.
They're going to come at us in the next election
and then the next midterm election.
We thought we drive a spike into Keynesianism
and redistribution 30 years ago.
We did not, so we'll just keep fighting away
with good arguments, persuasive arguments,
numerical arguments, numerical arguments.
I think the tide is turning.
It's moving in our direction.
We have much more work to do but I notice,
along with the oil drop and the dollar rise,
jobs are getting better, wages are picking
up.
This is because the instinct of our economy
is to grow.
Business is very resilient despite the fact
that you have an anti-business president,
breathtakingly anti-business president.
I'll give you an example of this.
I'm an economist.
I won't quote constitutional stuff.
The president says he wants corporate tax
reform.
My belief right now is that single most important
thing that would help the American economy
in the short run would be slashing of the
corporate tax rate and an end to the double
taxation of foreign profits parked overseas.
Single best thing we could do.
If you had that big tax cut, marginal tax
rate cut, and an improving dollar, that would
give the Fed cover to do what it needs to
do to try to get its affairs back in order
so they can write a good check again.
Now, Obama says, "I'm for corporate tax reform."
Then he goes to the State of Union message
and then he puts out his budget.
He says, "I don't really like those multinationals
that send the money abroad.
They're unpatriotic.
Here's the deal.
If they bring their money home ... " It's
about two trillion dollars worth.
Two trillion's a lot of money.
The whole economy is only about 17 trillion.
"They bring their money home.
I will tax them at 19% for the first year,
and then 14% thereafter."
I think that's right, or is it 14% and 9%.
Or, 19% and 14%.
That's a lousy deal.
They can do that now.
The way the system works you pay about 25%
overseas.
We're 35.
You pay 25% overseas.
You get to deduct that from your 35% but you
still have to pay 10% if you bring the money
home, so it's taxed twice.
Obama says, "I'm going to give you a big break
and tax you at 14%."
Ten is as high as they can go.
That's the break even point.
The current system, as bad as it is, is actually
better than the one he's proposing, and he
says he's for corporate tax reform.
I don't know what I think about that.
He must think, to use the words of one of
his advisors, that Americans are stupid.
Well we are not.
We are not, and my pal and yours Paul Ryan
is going to go after that.
We'll see if we can't do better, and hopefully
it will an election that will.
Thank you on behalf of Paul, whom I've known
for many years.
Thank you.
Let me raise a couple of other points.
Then I want to take your questions.
I don't get out much.
I'm dying to hear what's on your mind.
As much of a believer of economic incentives
and free markets and choice as I am, as much
as I acknowledge the need to roll back Obamacare
and substitute market choice and competition,
as much as I want to reform the entitlement
state, as much as I want to reward success
rather than punish it, I want to raise two
issues.
They're economic, yes, but they're not economic.
One of them is the issue of marriage, marriage.
Stay with me on this.
Every study shows, left of center, right of
center, virtually every study shows that married
people have higher incomes and greater wealth
than unmarried people.
By the way, as a practical guy who's had his
ups and downs in life I can just say to you
if you are divorced you can get remarried
for a long time.
It will stick.
Mine's 27 years and growing.
They also show that probably the single biggest
cause of poverty is broken families, unmarried
and broken families.
Third, they show that the government is subsidizing
broken families, fatherless families.
In fact, the government is even subsidizing
situations where two people live under the
same roof but neither of them work.
They have kids and the subsidizes that.
What I'm here to say, and it's a theme I've
been developing for many months, the culture
of marriage is one of the most important economic
solutions possible, as well as an inherently
moral solution as well.
We should do everything we can, everything
we can, whether it's cultural or tax or economic
or entitlement, to change this.
I want every presidential candidate to tackle
the issue of marriage and family breakup,
and the federal government's role in that.
It turns out the government plays an important
role in that.
The last democrat I worked for ... Woops,
I'm an ex-democrat.
Lot of Reagan people were ex-democrats.
Last democrat I worked for is Senator Pat
Moynihan who wrote a study about this regarding
black families and their pathologies.
He wrote that in the mid-60s.
He was completely trashed, trashed by the
academic institutions.
He was completely and utterly right, completely
and utterly right.
Read Jason Riley in the Wall Street Journal.
Now he's gone over to the Manhattan Institute.
He was on my radio show this past week.
He wrote a brilliant op-ed piece in the Wall
Street Journal about this very fact, about
this very fact.
It isn't only a black problem.
It has become a white problem as Charles Murray
has taught us, and it has been a brown problem.
In other words, it's just a problem.
We need more, healthier, longer marriages.
For the kids, yes, and for society.
On this point I'll just close.
One last point: I call it Kudlow 101.
Very simple.
If you're a child of a broken family, it's
predictable that you are going to fail and
may be enmeshed in poverty and have no upward
social mobility, and I hate that.
I hate the thought of that.
I mentor.
I mentor and I sponsor.
I'm in 12-step programs.
I'm in community programs.
First, go to school.
Go to school every day.
Get your high school diploma and then go on
a bit.
I don't care if you go to a four-year college
or not.
Get a technical degree, learn to fix things.
There's great money in that.
Whatever suits you.
You don't have to go to Princeton.
I went to Princeton.
By the way, I just want to digress for one
minute.
It is my great hope that the president of
the United States will not have an Ivy League
degree.
It's my great hope.
I am already agitating for a law ... My pal
Rand Paul and others want to have rules to
audit the Federal Reserve.
I have a better one for the Federal Reserve.
Pass a law that says any Ivy League economist
with an econometric model is automatically
disqualified for holding the post.
You think I'm kidding?
I'm not.
I've been there and I've done that, but I
digress.
I want the kid to go to school and get some
skills.
Then I want he or she to get a job, a job.
I want them to hold the job for a bunch of
years like we did, like we did.
You start at the bottom of the ladder.
You work your way up.
That's a very American notion.
I don't want to ever lose that.
That is as precious as free market capitalism.
Indeed, it is a cornerstone of free market
capitalism.
Hold onto a job.
Then start dating.
Now my wife calls it doing research.
Living together, jumping in the bed together,
we tried that.
Sometimes it works.
More than 50% of the time it doesn't work.
Just get to know each other.
Then get married.
Then get married and be married for several
years with a job for a bunch of jobs, and
then have the kid.
The trouble with today's story is it's being
done backwards.
They have the kid first before the marriage,
before the job, before the education, and
it is most regrettable.
This has to be changed.
To me as a guy who has fought for economic
freedom, and lower marginal tax rates, and
dregulation, and a sound dollar my entire
life, this marriage thing is looming larger
and larger.
The more I read, the more I'm convinced.
That's why I present it to you.
My final point this evening is on international
policy.
This is terribly important, too, as you know.
I was just reading Annelise Anderson's book.
Her dear husband, these are dear friends of
mine.
Marty just passed away but they put out this
great book about Reagan's great decisions.
Reagan used to always argue weakness at home
leads to weakness abroad, but strength at
home leads to strength abroad.
When your economy is solid at home you have
the resources to produce the natural security
and meet your commitments.
If you draw lines in the sand, then you meet
that commitment.
Unfortunately, today we have a soft economy.
We're not generating the resources.
Our friends don't respect us and our enemies
don't fear us.
This is a terrible situation, but it can be
fixed, it can be fixed, as long as we understand
the stakes are very high.
That's all I'm getting at.
My friend and frequent guest on the Kudlow
Report and on the radio show, General Jack
Keane, started me on this.
He compared this battle with the Islamic jihadist
radicals and the rest of the world as a battle
reminiscent of the battle between freedom
and communism in the last century.
I just raised it up and said, "General, can
I just call this a battle between freedom
and totalitarianism?"
That's what this is.
It's not just about one country or one border.
This is about a whole movement that wishes
to destroy us, our way of life, and our principles,
and our constitutions, and everything else.
We can't allow this to happen.
We need a plan but we need resolve.
We need an economy and we need resolve, and
we need a plan.
I will recommend to you a book written by
the mayor of London, Boris Johnson.
It's called the Churchill Factor.
Book's an easy read.
Mr. Johnson reminds us, says Churchill was
the most important figure in the 20th century,
the most important figure in the 20th century.
Why?
Because when Britain and the world needed
him, he was there to fight totalitarianism.
We didn't know at that point.
It looked like Nazism but it could have been
communism, etc. etc.
If he didn't fight it, nobody else would.
Meaning no disrespect, but FDR and the USA
wasn't there politically yet.
Meaning a lot of disrespect, the leaders of
Churchills own party were a bunch of appeasing
wusses.
On the other hand, the nobility of Britain,
half of them were Nazi sympathizers.
They figured Hitler might come in, put his
guy in charge nominally but they would continue
to live the great life that they thought they
were living.
Wrong, wrong.
We should never kid ourselves about the evils
of totalitarianism ever.
God bless there was Winston Churchill, a guy
who had seen bullets in several wars who understand.
He fought and he stood up and he had a lot
of courage.
I don't know who the Churchill is today.
I don't know that.
Not smart enough to know.
I know that there are a bunch of very smart,
conscionable, free market-oriented Republican
governors who are going to fight it out for
the nomination to be president, and I think
that's good.
As somebody who believes in free market competition
I say let the games begin.
I want to see the debates, etc. etc.
Alls I ask is that the next leader take account
of history lessons both recent and in the
past.
We can grow this economy at 3.5 to 4% like
we have for the last hundred years if we reward
success and choose free market choice over
government statism and entitlements.
That's one point.
We can achieve 3.5 to 4% growth if we pull
back on regulations and if we lighten the
tax burden, and we keep the dollar sound.
We can do this.
If we observe constitutional rules of law
and order we can do this.
We know how to do this.
If we have an ear and a sense of the importance
of a conservative, traditional cultural of
marriage, we can do this.
Then if we have, finally, a sense of the importance
of the battle that is going on internationally
between freedom and totalitarianism, we can
do this.
My message to you at the end of this talk,
as it was in the beginning, I'm an optimist,
but you and I must fight like hell in order
to win.
Thank you for inviting me.
You're way too kind.
I'm most grateful.
Nothing I've said that your president wasn't
talking about in his own way and will continue.
It's such an honor for me to be able to address
Hillsdale College.
With permission from our officials and moderators
and what not I would love to take a few questions.
Like I say, I don't get out much.
This is a hell of a crowd.
I don't think I've ever seen so many free
market conservatives under one roof before,
so God bless you.
If I had it to do over again I'd swap my Princeton
degree for yours, believe me.
I will do penance by going out there and actually
seeing Hillsdale.
I'm anxious to actually see it and meet the
kids, meet the kids who are the most important.
Anyway, please if you have a question or a
disagreement go right ahead.
Yes sir.
Speaker 3: Your comments on marriage were
good but there is some issues there sometimes.
Larry Kudlow: I'm sorry, I can't hear you,
sir.
Speaker 3: Is that better?
Hello?
Everyone can hear me except you, sir.
Anyway, your comments on marriage were good.
Larry Kudlow: Thank you.
Speaker 3: But, there's other issues sometimes.
You mentioned that fellow Mr. Hamm, right?
Larry Kudlow: Right.
Speaker 3: He has some issues with divorce.
I'm being a little facetious but the thing
is not always perfect.
I guess my point is, it's kind of goofy but
this is really travesties of justice I that
arena also.
Larry Kudlow: I suppose so.
I don't know.
Like I say, it's about progress, not perfection.
If you swing at the ball and hit a ground
out, you can come back again, get a base it.
You know what I mean.
You all know what I mean.
I'm not here to morally judge anybody, lord
knows.
You're talking to a Catholic convert who with
the help of God completely changed his life
20 years ago.
I'm not here to take your inventory.
All I'm saying is that in the economic zone,
in the economic sphere, it's not just about
tax cuts and regulations.
I'm expressing my worry that we are creating
permanent poverty pockets and a lack of upward
social mobility.
I'm saying to you that the evidence, the data,
are now coming in an overwhelming manner that
the decline of the culture of marriage and
the decline of marriages, and the increase
in family breakup, has had a devastating effect
on the kids, on the families, and on our economy.
That's what it's saying.
Speaker 4: Mr. Kudlow, how is it that the
theories of Samuelson and others on dealing
with the deficits and the way to grow the
economy, which I thought you nailed down copy
before, how is it they can still keep coming
to the fore, and what method could you propose
for economists to develop a definitive program
for what grows the economy and what doesn't
to the level it's on sort of a scientific
basis rather than an emotional basis.
Larry Kudlow: It's a great question, sir.
It's a very important question.
People with greater economic credentials than
I have puzzled with this question.
I would argue the evidence is clear.
You're implying you agree with that.
The evidence is clear.
Let me just go back one second.
I'm working with a co-author to write a book
about John F. Kennedy's tax cuts, as you know
that Kennedy was really the first post-world
war supply sider.
He lowered marginal tax rates.
He cut taxes for rich people, middle income
people, corporations, capital gains, dividends.
He was the last Democrat really to do so except
Bill Clinton, who was pushed into it by Newt
Gingrich, but I'll give Clinton credit, too.
Anyway, we had a boom in the 60s.
Before we destroyed the dollar and the land,
we had a boom, one of the best booms in American
history.
In the 1980s we lowered marginal tax rates,
limited government.
By the way, Kennedy was a stickler for the
budget.
He was a budget restraint guy.
It may not have been everything about him
that we like and love but on these issues
he got ... By the way, he insisted that the
dollar stay as good as gold.
My kind of guy.
Sorry I never met him.
Similar principles were laid down in the 80s
and similar principles were laid down in the
90s.
This is all in our lifetime.
We had huge booms.
I always love it when my friends on the left
tell me how bad lowering marginal tax rates
is.
Bill Clinton, he raised the rate from 31 to
40, yeah, but he also lowered the capital
gains rate from 28 to 20 and reformed welfare
and passed a free trade bill, had Graham-Rudman,
a bunch of other budget restraints that Gingrich
and the Republicans worked with him on.
My pal and I Steve Moore one night were on
the radio together and in the 80s and 90s,
which Obama has trashed ... He said none of
that stuff worked.
He calls it all trickle down.
In the 80s and 90s the United States created
almost 50 million new jobs in 20 years.
The expansion of our economy was greater than
the total gross domestic product of any European
country during that period.
In fact, the expansion of our GDP is almost
greater than the whole size of the European
Union.
We did this in two decades under sound policies,
what I will simply call free market economics,
Gladstonian liberalism, Milton Friedman, whatever,
Friedrich Hayek.
Obama actually calls it all trickle down.
Now, the 1970s, where we employed spending
and tax hikes and inflation and wage and price
controls, of course under a Republican.
Had to be.
Just great, Richard Nixon.
I'm sure he was a fine man.
I met him a few times, but he was a economic
moron and there's nothing we can do about
that.
It's history.
Actually, I'll throw in LBJ.
LBJ, Nixon, Ford, Carter, producing every
Keynesian trick in the bag, and this country
suffered mightily with inflation and unemployment
rising together.
By the way, it damaged us enormously overseas.
In the current situation ... Look, I believe
Republicans and Democrats frankly are pretty
equally to blame.
Since 2000 or 2001 we've grown by less than
2% a year.
We have had Republican president, Democrat
president.
We've had Republican congress, Democrat Congress.
We've grown by less than 2% a year.
You can look it up.
We've tried the same funny business, targeted
tax credits and increases of spending and
subsidies and destroying the value of the
dollar, overregulation.
We're not at here at dinner.
You can't get a loan if you're in the gun
business.
You actually can't hardly get a loan.
Maybe it's just beginning to start.
C&I loans are starting to rise.
Dodd-Frank has completely transmogrified and
stultified the entire banking business to
the point where bankers don't want to take
risk anymore.
Bankers are in the business of taking risks,
bit if you lose on the risk you lose money.
If you lose money, you know what?
One of our cherished legal traditions: if
you lose money on a consistent basis you go
bankrupt.
Hello, bankrupt.
We have laws and judges.
Whatever happened to that?
You have regulators standing over the shoulders
of every bankers so they won't make a so-called
bad loan.
The EPA is trying to stop the very revolution
of fossil fuels that has given us now energy
independence, world dominance, and better
economic growth.
I don't need to go on and on and on.
I'm just saying you are right, sir.
The trouble with that is it just never seems
to end.
We've got some pretty good people on our side.
The chairman of the economics department of
Harvard University, Greg Mankiw, he's a good
guy.
He's a terrific guy, served under W as the
head of the Council of Economic Advisors.
He's said it's become obvious now the difference
between right and wrong.
The dean of the Columbia business school,
Len Hubbard, who was also a former CEA chairman
under W. Larry Summers, who was really kind
of a moderate Clinton-Rubin conservative guy
in the 90s, comes back under Obama and sounds
like John Kenneth Galbraith or something like
that.
Who was Ken Galbraith?
Nevermind, it's not even important.
He was a big library who spend more money.
I don't know what to tell you.
The battle goes on.
Look, at the end of the day it's really easy
in a way.
At the end of the day it's a political questions,
and at the end of the day you come back to
what I said to you before.
You're going to have to fight like hell.
This is a democracy.
America is a great democracy.
It's one of the reasons why I'm so optimistic.
When America sees things going really badly
it makes changes.
It makes management changes through the ballot
box.
That's the way this thing's going to be settled.
That's the only way.
But I will say this to you, sir.
It's pretty clear now that we know what to
do.
You and I and a few others in this room could
sit down and fix the economy in 25 minutes.
Honestly, we know what to do.
The foreign policy thing?
Much more difficult, much more difficult.
But we know the difference between right and
wrong.
How we lost in 2012 I will never understand.
That was worse than Dewey and Truman, honest
to God.
You have to stand up and tell the voters what
you believe in.
That's the essence of politics.
I'm reading in the newspapers how Jeb Bush
has got all this money locked up in the nomination.
By the way, I like Jeb Bush.
This is not about Jeb Bush, but I'm just saying
that idea which we saw four years ago with
Mitt Romney, who's a fine man, terrible politician,
had all this money locked up.
I hear it on the radio where some kind of
anniversary of The Beatles ... Remember The
Beatles?
Money can't buy you love.
Think about that as a political axiom.
You know what buys you love?
Message, believes, and the character and strength
like a Churchill to stand up and fight for
it regardless of whatever short-term political
problems may exist.
We have a group called The Committee to Unleash
American Prosperity started by Steve Forbes,
myself, Steve Moore, and Art Laffer.
We're forming a committee of very distinguished
business men and women and academics, and
we are asking these candidates to come to
meetings.
We started the first couple in and your, going
to go around the country to have more where
they will be directly ... It's not a debate.
They will sit down, have a nice little supper,
and we'll directly answer questions from knowledgeable,
distinguished people.
That's what we're going to do.
I want that done.
I have so much respect for these guys.
I've known them for years, all of them.
I want to hear them actually what I want to
hear them say.
I don't want to fence around it.
I don't want to hedge around it.
I don't want to say one thing on the debate
and the next night have my press guy said
I didn't believe it.
I don't want any of that crap.
I want clear thinking and message.
You know what?
Here's a awful thing.
In terms of message in 2012, Obama's left-wing
message was a lot clearer.
He was the optimist.
Our guy, I interviewed him, I love him.
He was so good to me.
I probably interviewed him five or six times.
I would sit across from him knee to knee and
I to this day couldn't tell you what he really
believes in.
I'm probably smarter than your average bear.
I couldn't tell you.
Obama, on the other hand, had his talking
points.
You see his guys, campaign managers, on Charlie
Rose last night?
God, eat your heart out.
They're so clever.
Why can't we do that, conservatives get here's
what we believe in.
That's what's going to win.
The academic studies, sir, you are right,
but I don't know.
It hasn't happened in my lifetime and probably
never will.
Other questions.
I love this.
Come on, fire away.
Disagree, yell at me.
It's okay.
I do this for a living.
Yes.
Speaker 5: The American populous seems to
want ... Can you hear me up there, Mr. Kudlow?
Larry Kudlow: I just have to wet my whistle.
Speaker 5: American populous seems to want
congress, the left and the right, to legislate
from the middle.
In your opinion, are our countries solvable
Larry Kudlow: All depends where the middle
is, I guess.
This is a right of center country, has been
for a long time.
My former boss Ronald Reagan used to say the
following.
He said two things.
One, if you and I agree on 80% of an issue
and we disagree on 20%, we are not enemies.
Number two, Reagan would say give me half
a loaf now and I'll get the other half later.
I was in the room.
I was a kid.
I didn't sit at the cabinet table.
I sat at that chair against wall.
I heard him.
Now, Reagan made a lot of deals.
Not a lot of them were good.
He knows that, said so in his memoirs, particularly
the '82 spending deal.
He never got spending cuts for some minor
tax cuts, but blah blah blah. '81 he made
a brilliant deal on taxes and spending.
‘83 they salvaged Social Security for four
decades, '86 on tax reform.
These were all deals.
They were deals on the MX missile.
There were deals on setting up the les in
Europe.
I don't want to go through all the deals.
Reagan was one of the greatest labor negotiators
in history.
People forgot that.
The guy ran the Screen Actors Guild.
He was president of the Screen Actors Guild
seven times.
To this day he led the only strike of the
Screen Actors Guild against in those days
the movie bosses, the only strike ever.
I'm still a member of the Screen Actors Guild
because I did a bunch of commercials years
ago.
I don't recommend it.
It's not my kind of crowd but Reagan ran it
seven times, so he know how to face down Louie
Mayer.
In that sense Tip O'Neill was nothing.
In answer to your question.
I don't know where the middle is.
I think the middle's a lot further to the
right than other people may.
I'm not afraid to make a deal.
As long as you don't give up your principles,
such a thing is possible.
Presidents have done this before.
This guy in the White House, he doesn't even
want to sit down with you.
You go back to 2011 ... This is probably going
to be very unpopular but I'm going to stand
up for my old friend John Boehner, who was
an original Kemp supply sider.
Jack Kemp was my mentor.
Boehner had a deal with Obama on deficits,
entitlements and taxes.
Not tax rates but tax revenues from growth.
He had a deal in 2011 and he walks out of
the White House.
Then they hear the next hour or two that the
deal's been changed and Obama wanted another
400 billion dollars in taxes.
He knew he was breaking the deal.
He did it purposely to avoid the deal.
Since then we have not had a good sit down.
That was the end of it.
This is the tragedy of the story.
Reagan would never let that happen.
People say how Tip O'Neill this and that.
Let me just tell you something.
I knew Tip O'Neill.
I knew his staff, his speechwriters.
Tip O'Neill was no Ronald Reagan.
Reagan rolled O'Neill continuously.
You know why?
We had the votes.
We had a majority in the senate for six years
and we didn't have the house, but we did have
the house because then conservative boll weevil
Democrats voted Reagan so we could command
260-70 votes on every roll call, kicked Tip
O'Neill's assess, and get a decent deal done.
I'm yearning for those days and I think somehow
one of these governors ... I really do want
a governor.
I think the first term senate model has been
tried and found lacking.
I want a governor.
I believe from one of them will come such
a person.
Why do I believe that?
A, because I believe in America and its democracy,
B, because I believe in God.
I'm going to wind it up right there.
Thank you very much.